hello everyone welcome back to the
channel we've got another south by
southwest 2022 interview for you and
this one is for an excellent movie with
two incredible performers in it we have
some of the cast behind two leslie with
us andrea owen
congratulations oh my this this movie
just like rocked me to my core thank you
thank you so with a
festival premiere a lot of our viewers
won't know much about your movie just
yet so would either of you mind giving
us a brief synopsis of to leslie
probably not
pro probably we probably can't give you
a very succinct version but um we do
play in the film mother and son
um which is our second time we're
playing the second time
we played mother and son in bloodline
um
and
we're reprising that with very different
characters but a similar age dynamic yes
and
the film follows um
both of our characters and is written by
uh
somebody who partly lived this
experience
um and so it's sort of based on the
portrait of somebody's life but loosely
and has a much more
kind
ending
[Music]
and
i think that's the best that i can do
yeah i mean i mean
did you ask for a synopsis
i think that was pretty solid i think
you should give yourself more credit
there
oh good okay good i i i mean i think
it's it's
one of the one of the most kind of um
accurate and and and
impactful
portrayals of of
um
really
hardcore alcoholism that i've
ever seen
that's that's my synopsis of it
because that is just it's it's a kind of
a messy you know
thing that's hard to
synopsize is that a word yes without
judgment yeah yeah without
with judgment so much easier um yeah and
you know and morality and all of those
things but but without
any of that and just to take a snapshot
into somebody's life and spend some time
with them and see how they're
struggling and triumphing
is um
is quite unusual
actually in film
a lot of michael's director statement
focused on the power of empathy and how
film and storytelling is a very unique
way to be able to get that feeling that
you might not otherwise and i feel like
this movie very successfully does what
he laid out in his director's statement
andrea i have a very big question for
you right now because
your filmography always blows my mind it
is just absolutely packed with roles
that feel so different and bold and
often ones that signal to me as someone
who knows very little about that sphere
that they could be extremely challenging
so it's always made me wonder
does anything scare you have you ever
been offered a role that made you go
like i i don't know if i could do this
i've also wanted that
very i'm i'm get i i'm gonna get very
british now you know awkward um
so there's that
uh
[Music]
yeah it terrifies me to be part of crap
it's fair
um you know and everyone you know
defines crap as something
something different
but um
uh
you know
we do something that costs an awful lot
of money
and so it's wonderful when
that can bring
huge amounts of joy deep catharsis
terror you know whatever you're looking
for
in in the most brilliant way
in the most
um
the cream as it were
of
you know any of those emotions that
we're seeking
um
i am a bit terrified of you know
i i i i am
certainly terrified of crap
i think
but and i don't think i'm alone in that
i think no i would agree i would agree
yeah it's very difficult because when
you're presented with something that's a
bit crap
to put it in a more british way if any
if you want to make anything sound
british just say a bit
a bit of crap so
something something's a bit crap
and it's presented to you you
you're not
then
just occupying one role you're not doing
your one job
you suddenly find yourself as co-writer
as
you know yeah you're taking on a lot
more you you suddenly have all these
responsibilities that you you didn't
sign up right you weren't expecting and
you didn't want and
but when you're part of something and
you want to have agency and
you know because you because from the
inside out you just love the bones of it
um and you also want to produce it you
want to celebrate it and create it and
be part of sharing it with the world
that's a different feeling
um than than taking on those roles when
you haven't really sort of signed up for
them so
um
[Music]
i'd say that's what i'm
tentative about
it's not what i was expecting but that
that is that is spot on at a brilliant
answer that makes all the sense in the
world
yeah just making bad work but i think
that's universal for a lot of us isn't
it you know
oh maybe it's not universal might be
speaking completely no no no i think i
think i mean
at least within within what we do i
think that's yeah that's
i'll i'll confirm i have a deep fear of
of interviews not going well and not
being informative so i feel like it
could it really it could be universal
dependent on whatever you're passionate
about i feel like
if you're passionate about anything
that's inevitable
all right so
owen this is a
unique situation for you because you are
playing the person who basically went
through this experience and also wrote
the screenplay i'm not sure how involved
ryan was in the casting process but did
the fact that he wrote this role in your
playing him and you know a unique layer
that might not have been part of your uh
your audition experiences before it it
did um
but
it was one that we sort of
tried to stay away from from focusing on
um because you know it is
it is in a way ryan's experience but
it's also you know
not so so this character is is sort of
ryan but also not um
so you know when when michael
emailed me about it
i said oh this is the i'm i'm playing
the writer right can i can i meet him
can i talk to him you know would he be
open to that would he want to do that
and the response was kind of like
no go do your own thing
um
you know don't look he doesn't
the influence that he would have is
maybe not the the one that we want for
the movie um
so
so it didn't it didn't add
a lot other than the knowledge that
i i you know in whatever i did with
james i needed to
do justice to what he
wrote and to what he created um
but not so much try to beat him
if that makes sense absolutely so
bringing in michael now like blows my
mind that this is his first feature
because he's such a prolific tv director
is there anything that you noticed on
set about his experience working in
television so much that you know maybe
made this shooting experience different
if not enhanced it i think
uh it was like seeing somebody whose
wings
were finally unclipped
yeah
and and someone who who
really has been
trained through experience
to to to to knowing how to do it and not
having the kind of
i don't know what your experiences but
sometimes in films i i run into
directors who it's kind of it's kind of
like okay we have you know we have some
time we have the freedom to sort of
you know
mess about a little bit um
not to say that we didn't have freedom
but
michael knows how to how to get things
and and he knows how to communicate and
and he knows what he wants and and
that's
i really appreciate you know
especially his communication and and how
clear he is and this this kind of you
know understanding that he has of what
he's making is really
it it makes
my job a lot easier and a lot more
enjoyable yeah michael's a show runner
uh you know amongst other he has so many
strings to his bow but that's but that's
one of them yeah and
so he is he's innately
structured
and that
gives you a huge amount actually more
freedom because you know
nobody's worried about making the day
nobody's worried about not being time
for the important stuff um
and
watching him in that environment where
he now has really all of the command as
the director
um
but in
in
the context in a context that he admires
so much because he's a film he's a
cinephile you know so
so seeing him
be able to excel you know in that area
was
just really wonderful
joyful it was joyful being around him
yeah because you could you could feel
that he was so
not only ready for the opportunity but
really
embracing it yeah
it makes me feel better that he gives
off those vibes because this material is
so like this is why i could never act i
i can't imagine giving all of myself to
challenging material like this and being
able to you know come out the other side
it's a weird job it's a weird job i i
mean i know i found it really helpful
when we were on set just to have michael
as you know
a an extremely good director but also
just like
that kind of excited
inspired person who who was like
he had this warmth and this kind of like
compassion to
not only what he was making but also the
people who are making it with him and
there were a few moments where i was
like
i need help and and he was like yeah
he's great
well i think one of the markers of
knowing that you're working with a
wonderful director is you know a really
somebody who's going to make something
that's thoughtful and uh funny and
beautiful and full of life is uh
that
they are sort of able to
everybody wants to do well for them
every every
person on the set wants to do their best
for whoever it is and everybody wants to
do their best for michael
um and that's always a really good mark
a really good sign
of heading in some sort of
good direction yeah you never know where
quite where you're going with film but
you know
it's it's definitely a good sign but you
believe in the person that's kind of
leading it
and that's
that matters it always fills my heart to
hear about an environment on set like
that
what about for each other now because i
love talking about the value of a good
scene partner and you have some
sequences in this movie that i don't
think i'll ever forget so for each of
you what is something the other did as a
scene partner that i don't know helped
you out with something maybe even helped
you access something in your own
character that you wouldn't have been
able to reach without them
my god just being born
[Laughter]
couldn't we couldn't absolutely couldn't
have done it without you no
i mean i mean the movie wouldn't exist
without
you know well so i couldn't have done it
at all but he is so brilliant he's so
brilliant i i i kind of sometimes forget
that you are you
when when we were working yeah um
which is probably just because it would
be good weird if a northern like uh
it's wonderful for me because then like
we can you know set up another shot and
i can just talk to you yeah like we can
just
be ourselves yeah and then but then when
you know when we're doing it
it's very easy to forget that i am
acting with her um
which is not always an easy thing to
forget at least not for me
um so
yeah that was that's i mean that's kind
of the thing
that's the big thing and our
relationship started i mean how old were
you when we were standing on that pier
and
clicking 16. i was going to say 15 but
yeah 16 16 i think it was 16 15 and we
were smoking those absolutely awful
honey roses terrible pretend
cigarettes um
as mother and son but really more like
siblings yeah because that dynamic was
really
much more like siblings than mother and
son um
and so and
having having
played alongside one another and
it's kind of amazing to come back to
i suppose it's it's almost like you said
it's like when you mentioned the phrase
scene partner
it's like coming back to a
repertory theater or class something you
know something that's familiar yeah
you're you kind of come in and it's like
oh yeah this is how we do this
yeah that rapport
just uh
takes a long time takes years to build
up what breaks my heart i have to like
wind down with you guys i feel like i
could i could get into the layers of
this movie in your process all day long
but i have to let you go huge
congratulations on to leslie i meant
what i said earlier you are both
exceptional in the movie it is fantastic
enjoy austin and south by southwest